you know his name
i'm the doctor you know his face
says and you know his mission always
search for truth
my truth is in the stars unless you're
not from the united kingdom then you
probably don't know any of those things
now relive over 30 years of classic
sci-fi television that will determine
once and for all
if you're a fan of doctor who or a
doctor who fan
[Laughter]
classic doctor who meet the doctor
a time lord from the planet gallifrey
who travels through space-time in a
machine called the tardis
and if that's already too weird for you
tap out now because it's about to get a
whole lot weirder
on the planet of the cheetah people
intelligent carnivores journey through
three decades of adventure
as the show or i mean the doctor keeps
things fresh by regenerating into new
bodies every few years
like the crabby old man doctor who
doesn't shut up
the beetle haircut childlike doctor you
caused me
a great deal of trump god i'm very glad
to hear it
the snake tatted kung fu austin powers
doctor
the this is what most people think all
of classic doctor who is doctor
how about jenny baby don't forget to
brush it the he seems nice doctor
it's absolutely splendid the kind of
arrogant even for the doctor doctor
a noble bro the almost out of gas
coasting on goodwill doctor yeti
autumn's daleks
cyberman accelerians and the tv movie
one-off george lazenby doctor
[Music]
but no matter which doctor is operating
the tardis one thing remains constant
he is either the most overrated or
underrated doctor of all time
in either the most overrated or
underrated era of the show
okay look getting doctor who fans to
agree on who's the best doctor is like
trying to watch every episode of doctor
who
it's pretty much impossible so why even
try
watch as the doctor and his companions
take on some of the most iconic villains
of all time
like the daleks exterminate him
examinate him
exterminate him the cyberman we meet
then spend the other 90 of the show
watching whatever villains the crew
could throw together on a low budget
like killer mannequins
[Music]
the bubble wrap monster
rubber spiders
[Music]
the [ __ ] from pulp fiction i will pay
eight kilos for the next shipment
a series of dudes with pockets on their
heads there's a devil from hell
the inflatable plastic chair of doom
[Music]
and some villains that it sounds like
they're just making up on the spot
they're demons from the planet deimos
watch them face off and story serialized
across
three four six or even ten episodes
jam-packed with enough plot to fill
maybe two we knows are able to live on
the surface and that they must about
immunity
perhaps it is a drug is it
failing them now why are they come on
whovians even you have to admit this
show is very
deliberately drawn out
witness the paradox that is classic
doctor who a show that's both timeless
and completely out of date
what you need is a jolly good smack
bottom thrill as it seems to predict
future phenomena like the matrix
ghost must have his own link with the
matrix the board
stephen king i should have to go to the
dark tower and
b-movie according to classical
aerodynamics it's impossible for a
bumblebee to fly
while also being completely
inappropriate for modern times one thing
i could swear it was a chinese
and i feel no pain the opium
are they all chinese gutter scrapings of
shanghai and one [ __ ]
and that's just from the episode the
towns of wing chang i understand we
all look the same wow
so if you like tv shows that you can
easily kick back and watch on netflix
then definitely don't start watching
doctor who i
am confused as this completionist
nightmare will send you scrambling to
find episodes of the bbc erased decades
ago
by hunting down dozens of dvd box sets
animated recreations and audio plays
while you secretly pray that all of it
just magically turns up like those
episodes from africa
but if you do somehow make it through
all 26 series specials and tv movies
then answer me this
why do doctor who fans get so angry
every time people call him doctor who
i'm the doctor i keep telling you that
when that's what the show called him for
18 years
you don't understand i i knew you
wouldn't never mind
starring easily defeated dollar x
slow dance
convoluted plots you think for one
moment that i forget that i bear the
sacred blood of the franz zion greek
i've exodus kept on the eating crystal
not about to transfer the crystal to the
hecate the more the tucks will doubt you
the more you must convince or flock that
you are your taxer
bad fight scenes
[Music]
nice to see you again
club lines and you're both not sure
you're not bullshitting an alliance
unconscious no i shot you shan't take
him you found the inner
top compartment containing three daleks
and villains who yell
the accumulation of evidence is
overwhelming the mentions are heading
towards sector five
okay okay i'll do anything i'll listen
to the big finish audio place
i watch canine company just make it stop
make it stop
inspector spacetime
so the sonic screwdriver that's
basically just a fancy door opener right
it's only a door handle yep that's what
i thought
now that you know the doctor's history
you're ready to check out our trailer
for modern doctor who
covering everything since the 2005
reboot click above to check it out
trust me i'm the epic voice guy i am
definitely a madman with a box
hello i'm the doctor would you like a
jelly baby